TO ORDER. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY ATKINS. BECKER.
BLAKE SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. DALLY. DODD DURAZO.
EGGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MINH. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OKOBO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER
WILK. HERE TODAY. YES. CORTEZ.
MEMBERS MEMBERS. THE QUORUM IS
PRESENT. I'D LIKE TO ASK MEMBERS
AND GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER
MICHELLE. AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE. SISTER MICHELLE.
SO LET US GATHER IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS
TO BE SELF-EVIDENT, THAT ALL
PERSONS ARE CREATED EQUAL, THAT
THEY ARE ENDOWED BY THEIR
CREATOR WITH CERTAIN
UNALIENABLE, UNALIENABLE RIGHTS,
THAT AMONG THESE ARE LIFE,
LIBERTY, AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS. GRACIOUS GOD OF THE
PAST, PRESENT AND FUTURE. AS WE
CELEBRATE THE BIRTHDAY OF OUR
NATIONAL INDEPENDENCE, WE
CONFESS OUR ONGOING DEPENDANCE
ON YOU. WE PRAY THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE REAL THE
COURAGE OF OUR FORBEARERS ON
THESE TEMPESTUOUS DAYS. MAY OUR
FREEDOM OF SPEECH SERVE TO BUILD
COMMUNITY AND COLLABORATION. MAY
OUR FREEDOM OF WORSHIP LEAD US
TO GRATITUDE FOR ALL WE HAVE
RECEIVED. AND MAY OUR FREEDOM
FROM WANT AND FEAR ENRICH US
WITH CREATIVE IDEAS FOR ENSURING
THE LIFE, LIBERTY, AND HAPPINESS
OF ALL OF OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS. MAY ALL THAT IS HIGH
AND FINE IN US RISE TO GREET
EACH NEW DAY CONFIDENT THAT WE
WILL ACHIEVE THE IDEALS THAT WE
KNOW TO BE SELF-EVIDENT. AMEN
MEMBERS AND GUESTS, PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
AND TO SERVE THE PUBLIC WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR.
OKAY SENATOR GROVE, FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I HAVE A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY. WHAT IS
THAT. IS IT IS IT THE PRACTICE
AND CUSTOM OF THE SENATE THAT
THE SENATE RULE 55 BE SUSPENDED
WHEN MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WISH TO BE
PRESENT IN THE CHAMBER? SENATOR,
THAT IS THE RULES OF THE SENATE.
SO, SINCE THAT'S THE CASE, I'M
WONDERING IF WE NEED TO SUSPEND
SENATE RULE 55 TO ALLOW GOVERNOR
MCGUIRE TO BE IN THE CHAMBER
WITH US TODAY. SENATOR, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INQUIRY. GIVEN THAT
THE PERSON IN QUESTION IS A
MEMBER OF THE SENATE AND ONLY IN
AN ACTING CAPACITY, I THINK IT
WE'LL FIND THAT THAT RULE DOES
NOT NEED TO BE SUSPENDED TODAY,
BUT WE APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THAT TO OUR ATTENTION. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CLARIFICATION, SIR.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE. PAGING
ACTING GOVERNOR MCGUIRE. THE
FRONT DESK. OKAY. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, WITHOUT OBJECTION,
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO SENATE. THIRD READING
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM 39. SENATE
RESOLUTION 99 BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. SHE IS PREPARED SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION 99
BY SENATOR BLAKE SPEER. RELATIVE
TO THE 4TH OF JULY. SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER, A MEMBERS. LET'S
GIVE SENATOR BLAKE SPEER OUR
ATTENTION, PLEASE. SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION 99,
RECOGNIZING THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
INDEPENDENCE DAY ON JULY 4TH.
THIS IS OUR MOST SIGNIFICANT
NATIONAL HOLIDAY. NOW MORE THAN
EVER, WE NEED TO BE REMINDED OF
THE PROFOUND IMPORTANCE OF OUR
SHARED VALUES AS AMERICANS AND
AS CALIFORNIANS THAT THIS DAY
HOLDS FOR OUR NATION AND FOR
THIS GREAT STATE. ALL OF YOU
KNOW, THE HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY, BUT I JUST WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE VERY BEGINNING,
WHICH WAS ON JULY 4TH, 1776. OUR
FOREFATHERS TOOK THE BOLD STEP
OF DECLARING INDEPENDENCE FROM
BRITAIN, SETTING IN MOTION THE
BIRTH OF AMERICAN DEMOCRACY AND
ARTICULATING THE PRINCIPLES THAT
CONTINUE TO GUIDE US AND THE
WORLD'S OTHER DEMOCRACIES TODAY.
THE SECOND SENTENCE OF THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE,
WHICH WHICH MICHELLE GORMAN
BEGAN HER PRAYER WITH TODAY, IS
ARGUABLY ONE OF THE BEST KNOWN
AND MOST CONSEQUENTIAL SENTENCES
IN THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE BECAUSE
IT CLEARLY STATES A MORAL
STANDARD OF HUMAN
SELF-DETERMINATION THAT WE HAVE
SPENT NEARLY 250 YEARS IN
CONSTANT STRUGGLE TO ACTUALIZE
THE SENTENCE THAT BEGINS, WE
HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE SELF
SELF-EVIDENT AND ENDS WITH LIFE,
LIBERTY, AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS. ALEXANDER HAMILTON,
ONE OF OUR NATION'S FOUNDING
FATHERS, PUT THIS SAME CONCEPT A
DIFFERENT WAY. HE SAID. THE
SACRED RIGHTS OF MANKIND ARE NOT
TO BE RUMMAGED FOR AMONG OLD
PARCHMENTS OR MUSTY RECORDS.
THEY ARE WRITTEN, AS WITH A
SUNBEAM IN THE WHOLE VOLUME OF
HUMAN NATURE BY THE HAND OF
DIVINITY ITSELF, AND CAN NEVER
BE ERASED OR OBSCURED BY MORTAL
POWER. OUR FOUNDING FATHERS WERE
STATESMEN AND PATRIOTS, BUT WE
KNOW THAT TODAY. SPEAKING ABOUT
THE TIMELESS AND UNALIENABLE
NATURE OF THESE RIGHTS IS NOT
ENOUGH. HERE IN CALIFORNIA, AND
SPECIFICALLY HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE, WE
STRUGGLE EVERY DAY WITH THE
CHARGE TO MAKE REAL WHAT THESE
RIGHTS TO SELF-DETERMINATION,
FREEDOM, LIBERTY, EQUALITY, AND
THE PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS MEANS.
CENTERING OUR CURRENT POLICY
DEBATES IN THE FRAMEWORK OF OUR
AMERICAN HISTORY. I OFTEN THINK
ON THE 4TH OF JULY ABOUT
FREDERICK DOUGLASS AND HIS
KEYNOTE ADDRESS IN 1852, WHICH
WAS ENTITLED WHAT TO THE SLAVE
IS THE 4TH OF JULY. HE
RECOGNIZED THE HYPOCRISY OF
ENSLAVING FELLOW HUMANS WHILE
CELEBRATING THE IDEALS OF JULY
4TH. HE SAID, THE 4TH OF JULY IS
YOURS, NOT MINE. YOU MAY
REJOICE, I MUST MOURN. IT'S
WORTH RECOGNIZING THAT
JUNETEENTH, OUR MOST RECENT
FEDERAL HOLIDAY, IS CELEBRATED
JUST TWO WEEKS AND ONE DAY
BEFORE THE 4TH OF JULY. THIS
FEDERAL HOLIDAY IS THE FIRST NEW
NATIONAL HOLIDAY IN NEARLY 30
YEARS. PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
SIGNED THE JUNETEENTH NATIONAL
INDEPENDENCE DAY ACT INTO LAW
JUST THREE DAYS AGO. OR SORRY,
JUST THREE YEARS AGO. BOTH OF
THESE HOLIDAYS, JULY 4TH AND
JUNETEENTH, RECOGNIZE FREEDOM,
NATIONAL FREEDOM AND PERSONAL
FREEDOM. AND BOTH OF THESE
HOLIDAYS, WHICH ARE
COMPLEMENTARY AND SHOW OUR
COUNTRY'S EVOLUTION, REQUIRE US
TO REMEMBER THAT THE PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE COMES FROM THE
CONSTANT STRUGGLE FOR THE
PROMISE OF THE WORDS WRITTEN 248
YEARS AGO AT OUR NATION'S BIRTH.
THOSE WITH LESS PRIVILEGE,
MINORITIES, WOMEN, PEOPLE OF ALL
ABILITIES, GENDERS, RACES, AND
ETHNICITIES HAVE CONSISTENTLY,
DOGGEDLY AND WITH FIERCE
COMMITMENT INSISTED ON THE
RIGHTS THAT AMERICA HAS
PROMISED. THE 4TH OF JULY
REMINDS US THAT DESPITE OUR
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS AND OUR
PERSPECTIVES, WE ARE ONE PEOPLE
UNITED IN OUR PURSUIT OF LIFE,
LIBERTY AND HAPPINESS. ON THE
FOURTH, LET US CELEBRATE THE
REMARKABLE JOURNEY OF OUR
NATION, RECOGNIZING HOW FAR
WE'VE COME WHILE ACKNOWLEDGING
THE WORK THAT STILL LIES AHEAD,
I URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO JOIN ME
IN SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION
HONORING THE SPIRIT OF
INDEPENDENCE DAY AND ENCOURAGING
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO CELEBRATE
THIS 4TH OF JULY WITH PRIDE,
REFLECTION, AND HOPE FOR OUR
SHARED FUTURE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER. THE RESOLUTION HAS
BEEN PLACED BEFORE THE BODY. I
SEE A MICROPHONE UP FROM SENATOR
JONES. SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND SENATORS, I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SR 99 AND THANK
OUR ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR BRINGING THIS TO THE
FLOOR TODAY WITH PERMISSION TO
READ, MR. PRESIDENT, I'D LIKE TO
SHARE SOME FOUNDING THOUGHTS ON
INDEPENDENCE DAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. JOHN ADAMS, WHEN
WRITING ABOUT INDEPENDENCE DAY
WAS VERY PROPHETIC IN HOW
AMERICA WOULD COME TO CELEBRATE
THE JULY 4TH CELEBRATION OR
MEMORY HONOR OF WHAT HAD
HAPPENED IN THAT SIGNING OF THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE. AND
IT'S VERY POIGNANT. I THINK, I
HOPE FOR ALL OF US ON WHAT HE
SAID AND HOW WE HAVE COME TO
CELEBRATE THE HOLIDAY. AS HE
DESCRIBES INDEPENDENCE DAY WILL
BE THE MOST MEMORABLE EPOCHA IN
THE HISTORY OF AMERICA. I AM APT
TO BELIEVE THAT IT WILL BE
CELEBRATED BY SUCCEEDING
GENERATIONS AS THE GREAT
ANNIVERSARY FESTIVAL. IT OUGHT
TO BE SOLEMNIZED WITH POMP AND
PARADE, WITH SHEWS GAMES, SPORTS,
GUNS, BELLS, BONFIRES AND
ILLUMINATIONS. ILLUMINATIONS.
FROM ONE END OF THIS CONTINENT
TO THE OTHER END OF THIS
CONTINENT. FROM THIS TIME
FORWARD, FOREVERMORE. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SR 99. THANK YOU,
SENATOR JONES. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
RESOLUTION? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SENATOR BLAKESTER, YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
THE DEBATE IF YOU WISH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
OVERALL, TO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY. AYE. DODD. DARAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE. OR
DATO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR MEN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE. ATROPOS.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO.
RUBIO. AYE. SATO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
SENATOR BLAKE, SPIRIT MOVES A
CALL. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING, AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM 190. ITS ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE ITEM 190.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 247 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI. THE
FLOOR AUTHOR IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 247 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI. AN ACT RELATING TO
EDUCATION FINANCE BY PROVIDING
THE FUNDS NECESSARY THEREFOR
THROUGH AN ELECTION FOR THE
ISSUANCE AND SELL OF BONDS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND FOR
THE HANDLING AND DISPOSITION OF
THESE FUNDS, AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR NEWMAN, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AS A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR OF AB 247 WITH SENATOR
GLAZER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MURATSUCHI MIKE FONG AND LORI
WILSON, I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
THE KINDERGARTEN THROUGH GRADE
12 SCHOOLS AND LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, PUBLIC EDUCATION,
FACILITIES MODERNIZATION, REPAIR
AND SAFETY BOND ACT OF 2024.
WHEN APPROVED BY THE STATE'S
VOTERS IN NOVEMBER, THE THIS
SCHOOL FACILITIES BOND WILL
PROVIDE $10 BILLION IN
DESPERATELY NEEDED STATE
MATCHING FUNDS FOR K THROUGH 12
AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS. THE LAST SUCCESSFUL
STATEWIDE SCHOOL BOND WAS PASSED
IN 2016, AND AT THIS POINT, ALL
FUNDS FROM THAT BOND HAVE BEEN
FULLY EXPENDED FOR K THROUGH 12
EDUCATION. THIS BOND WILL
SUPPORT REPAIRS AND UPGRADES OF
EXISTING FACILITIES, NEW
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS, LEAD
ABATEMENT, CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION FACILITIES. ELIGIBLE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN ACCESS THE
EXPANDED FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
ASSISTANCE DESIGNED TO AID LOW
WEALTH DISTRICTS, WHICH FACE
CHALLENGES IN GENERATING LOCAL
FUNDS AND ENABLING THEM TO
RECEIVE ONE UP TO 100% OF
CONSTRUCTION COSTS THROUGH STATE
GRANTS. ENHANCING AND
STREAMLINING THIS LONG STANDING
PROGRAM IS A PRACTICAL SOLUTION
TO ADDRESSING FUNDING INEQUITIES
WITHOUT COMPROMISING THE OVERALL
EFFECTIVENESS AND SUSTAINABILITY
OF THE PROGRAM. AB 247 STRIKES
AN ESSENTIAL BALANCE BY
INTRODUCING A SLIDING SCALE THAT
INCREASES STATE GRANT AMOUNTS
BASED ON A DISTRICT'S ABILITY TO
GENERATE LOCAL FUNDS AND THE
PERCENTAGES OF LOW INCOME FOSTER
CARE AND ENGLISH LEARNER
STUDENTS IN A DISTRICT. THIS
BALANCED APPROACH PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO HIGH NEED
DISTRICTS WHILE MAINTAINING A
SUSTAINABLE AND BROAD, BROADLY
SUPPORTED FUNDING MODEL.
STATEWIDE, AB 247 ALSO CREATES A
MECHANISM FOR ASSISTING SMALL
AND PRIORITY SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
THOSE WITH LOW BONDING CAPACITY
AND HIGH PERCENTAGES OF LOW
INCOME FOSTER CARE AND ENGLISH
LEARNER STUDENTS IN APPLYING FOR
AND ACCESSING FACILITIES FUNDS.
SOME OF THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING
PROVISIONS. SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS
FOR SPECIFIC NEEDS SUCH AS
SCHOOL KITCHENS, GYMNASIUMS,
LIBRARIES, TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOMS. CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION, AS WELL AS
PROJECTS TO ADVANCE STATE ENERGY
GOALS AND ADAPT TO HIGHER
TEMPERATURES. BUILDING
REPLACEMENT FUNDING FOR ELIGIBLE
FACILITIES, WHICH ARE AT LEAST
2075 YEARS OLD. AUTHORIZATION
FOR DEDICATED BOND DOLLARS TO BE
USED TO FUND KITCHENS,
PRESCHOOLS, HEALTH SERVICES,
SEISMIC RETROFITS, BROADBAND
INSTALLATION AND SCHOOL
GREENING. IT ALSO A REQUIREMENT
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS RECEIVING
STATE BOND DOLLARS TO COMPLETE A
FACILITIES MASTER PLAN FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNDER AB TWO,
47 NEW BOND FUNDS WILL BE
MANAGED IN THE SAME MANNER AS
CURRENT BOND FUNDS THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. OVERALL, AB
247 REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT
STEP FORWARD IN ENSURING MORE
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF SCHOOL
FACILITY FUNDS ACROSS OUR GREAT
STATE WHILE BALANCING THE NEED
FOR GREATER EQUITY WITH THE
PRACTICAL REALITIES OF OUR
CURRENT FISCAL CONSTRAINTS,
THEREBY ENSURING THAT ALL
DISTRICTS, ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH
THE GREATEST NEED, CAN RECEIVE
THE SUPPORT. THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY REQUIRE. I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR I VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN. I SEE
MICROPHONES UP FROM SENATOR
JONES AND SENATOR ATKINS. WE'LL
GO NEXT TO SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS,
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TODAY TO AB
247. THE EDUCATION BOND. BUT I
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT I AM NOT
OPPOSING FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES. I THINK THAT THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
ALL DISCUSSED HERE. EDUCATION
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY IN
CALIFORNIA. THE VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE GIVEN US PROP
98. THAT CERTAINLY UNDERSCORES
THE IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION FOR
THEM. IT WASN'T TOO LONG AGO
THAT WE HAD $100 BILLION SURPLUS
THAT WE COULD HAVE CERTAINLY
USED SOME OF THOSE DOLLARS, TO
FUND THE PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PREVIOUSLY DESCRIBED. WE COULD
ALSO DIVERT FUNDING FROM SOME
OTHER ISSUES THAT MAYBE WOULDN'T
BE SUCH A PRIORITY IN A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S AND VOTERS MINDS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I'M OPPOSING THE
MECHANISM OF BONDS IN GENERAL,
BONDS ARE THE MOST EXPENSIVE WAY
FOR GOVERNMENT TO PAY FOR
THINGS. WE'RE GOING TO BE,
SHACKLING FUTURE LEGISLATURES
AND THE TAXPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA
WITH DEBT THAT WILL BE CONTINUED
ON FOR DECADES. THIS SCHOOL
FACILITY ISSUE IS NOT NEW. IT
ALREADY EXISTED A FEW YEARS AGO
AND HAS BEEN CONTINUOUSLY
EXISTING. WE SHOULD BE
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR WITHOUT BONDS. WE
SHOULD HAVE PRIORITIZED THE
SPENDING. THEN WHEN WE HAD THE
MONEY, RATHER THAN PUTTING IT ON
THE STATE CREDIT CARD THAT THE
TAXPAYERS WILL PAY WILL BE ON
THE HOOK TO PAY BACK. WITH MANY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF INTEREST.
I WILL BE VOTING NO. THANK YOU,
SENATOR JONES. I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR ATKINS,
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR LAIRD,
SENATOR ATKINS, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE. I
WANT TO COMMEND THE PRO TEM AND
THE SENATORS WHO WORKED
DILIGENTLY FOR MONTHS TO PUT
TOGETHER THIS EDUCATION BOND. I
SUPPORT EDUCATION BONDS. I KNOW
IT WASN'T AN EASY FEAT. THE
FUNDS THAT WE INVEST IN THIS
BOND ARE MEANT TO ADDRESS
TODAY'S CHALLENGES AND PLAN FOR
A MORE EQUITABLE FUTURE, AS THE
FLOOR MANAGER SAID, IN WHICH
STUDENTS CAN GET A QUALITY
EDUCATION REGARDLESS OF THEIR
BACKGROUND, NEIGHBORHOOD, OR THE
INCOME LEVEL OF THEIR FAMILY. AS
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED,
THE BOND MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN K THROUGH 12 AND
OUR INCREDIBLE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. AND WHILE I THINK THIS
MEASURE ADDRESSES MANY IMPORTANT
ISSUES, I AM CONCERNED THAT OUR
CSU AND UC INSTITUTIONS WERE NOT
INCLUDED. THE CSU AND UC SYSTEMS
ARE CRITICAL TO THE ECONOMY OF
OUR STATE. THEY'RE WORLD CLASS
INSTITUTIONS, VERY COMPETITIVE
TO GET INTO. THEY DRIVES
INNOVATION AND ATTRACTS TOP
EXPERTS IN MANY FIELDS TO OUR
STATE. THEY EDUCATE OUR
WORKFORCE, WHICH KEEPS
CALIFORNIA COMPETITIVE GLOBALLY,
AND THEY PROVIDE LIFE CHANGING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
ON TOP OF THAT, THEY OFFER
IMPORTANT RESOURCES TO OUR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MEDICAL CARE,
VETERINARY CARE, LABOR CENTERS
AND SO MUCH MORE. THESE
INSTITUTIONS HAVE SPENT THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES TRYING TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE AND TO DEAL WITH
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
CONTINUING TO HAVE STATE OF THE
ART CLASSROOMS FOR THE STUDENTS.
WE SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT OUR
FUTURE AND THAT WORLD CLASS
INSTITUTIONS REMAIN JUST THAT. I
THINK WE MISS THAT OPPORTUNITY.
SO I ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE OUR
PRESIDING OFFICER, WHO SPENT A
LOT OF TIME HAVING SERVED AS A
CSU TRUSTEE HIMSELF AND WORKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE INCLUDED
ALL OF OUR INSTITUTIONS OF
LEARNING FROM K THROUGH 12
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND OUR OTHER
HIGHER INSTITUTIONS OF LEARNING.
I AM GOING TO SUPPORT THIS. I
MUST WE NEED THE RESOURCES TO
UPGRADE OUR SCHOOLS. SO IT IS A
RELUCTANT YES, AND I WISH AND
HOPE THAT IN FUTURE ENDEAVORS
THAT WE REALLY TRY NOT TO LEAVE
HIGHER EDUCATION BEHIND.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ATKINS. SENATOR LAIRD,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 247 AND I SIT
AS ONE OF THE THREE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE SENATE ON
THE STATE ALLOCATION BOARD. WE
RECEIVE ALL THE APPLICATIONS
FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS AROUND THE
STATE FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION, FOR
REPAIRS, FOR THE THINGS THEY
NEED. AND WE RAN OUT OF BOND
MONEY FOR THIS PURPOSE ROUGHLY
THREE YEARS AGO OR FOUR YEARS
AGO. AND WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING
IS WE HAVE BEEN FROM THE GENERAL
FUND PUTTING IN WHATEVER IT
TAKES FOR ONE YEAR OF THE
GENERAL FUND TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE BRIDGE TO THIS VERY BOND. AND
IT WAS SAID THAT, GEEZ, WHEN WE
HAD A SURPLUS, WE SHOULD HAVE
SPENT MONEY. WELL, FOR TWO YEARS
WE DID. FOR TWO YEARS WE SPENT
THAT SURPLUS MONEY TO BRIDGE THE
MONEY TO SCHOOLS FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND NEW
CONSTRUCTION TO GET TO THIS
MOMENT SO THAT AT A TIME WHEN
THE BUDGET DOESN'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY, WE CAN GO TO THE
VOTERS AND WHY DO YOU GO TO THE
VOTERS? YOU GO TO THE VOTERS TO
DO INVESTMENTS THAT MOVE US
AHEAD. THAT SINGLE ALLOCATIONS
FROM THE BUDGET CAN AFFORD. AND
THAT IS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT. THIS
IS JOBS. THIS IS MAKING SURE
THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE CONSTRUCTED
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS AND WE
HAVE THE MONEY. AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE FISCAL SITUATION OF
THE STATE, YOUR BENCHMARK AND
THIS COULD COME UP IN ANOTHER
BOND DISCUSSION LATER IN THIS
EVENING. YOUR BENCHMARK IS THAT
YOU CANNOT HAVE BONDED
INDEBTEDNESS. THAT'S MORE THAN 5
TO 6% OF YOUR GENERAL FUND
BUDGET. THIS BONDED INDEBTEDNESS
IS WITHIN THAT. AND SO THAT IS
WHAT BONDS ARE FOR. AND SO
CLEARLY WHAT THIS IS, IS WE WILL
NOT HAVE THE MONEY FOR SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION IF WE DON'T DO
THIS. THIS IS FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND IS AN INVESTMENT IN
OUR FUTURE, IN OUR SCHOOLS, IN
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM, IN JOBS,
INVESTMENTS WITHIN THE STATE'S
FISCAL ABILITY TO CONTINUE WHAT
WE WERE ABLE TO BRIDGE TO THE
SURPLUS AND OTHER STUFF TO GET
HERE THAT IS WHY THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT. THAT'S WHY WE NEED IT.
THAT'S WHY WE SHOULD VOTE YES ON
AB 247. AND IT'S WHY EACH OF US
SHOULD GO TO THE VOTERS AND TELL
THEM THIS IS A GOOD INVESTMENT,
AND IN NOVEMBER THEY SHOULD MAKE
IT. I REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR LAIRD. SENATOR MIN,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TO ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT
PRO TEMPORE. I GUESS EMERITA,
FOR THREE AND A HALF YEARS,
UNTIL RECENTLY, I SAT ON THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
EDUCATION AND WAS FACED
CONTINUALLY WITH THE SEVERE AND
LONG STANDING FAILURE TO INVEST
IN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND MANY
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AT
OUR CSUS PARTICULARLY, AND ALSO
OUR UCS. AND WE FAILED TO MAKE
THOSE INVESTMENTS WHEN WE HAD
LARGE SURPLUSES IN THIS STATE,
I'M TOO AM DISAPPOINTED THAT WE
DID NOT SEE A LARGER INVESTMENT
IN THE UCS AND CSUS IN OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
WITH THIS BOND, BUT I'M LEAVING
THE SENATE OBVIOUSLY, THIS YEAR
WOULD URGE MY COLLEAGUES, WHEN
WE AGAIN, ARE AT A POINT WHEN WE
HAVE HIGH WATER, WHEN WE HAVE
SURPLUSES TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS, BECAUSE THEY ARE
BECOMING VERY CRITICAL, THEY'RE
IMPACTING THESE INSTITUTIONS
ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY TEACH THE
NEXT GENERATION OF OUR WORKERS
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THAT BEING
SAID, I WILL VOTE FOR THIS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR MIN.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE? MEMBERS, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR NEWMAN,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE
DEBATE? I WOULD THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SO FIRST LET ME
AFFIRM AND ALIGN MY COMMENTS
REGARDING THE OMISSION OF THE
TWO HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS IN
THIS BOND ABOUT WHICH THE
PRESIDING OFFICER SPOKE SO
ELOQUENTLY AND PERSUASIVELY.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, WHEN THE
MEASURE WAS HEARD IN THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. LET ME ALSO
POINT OUT SOMETHING YOU ALL
KNOW, BUT FOR THE RECORD, THAT
THERE WAS VERY CLEAR CONSENSUS
WITHIN THE SENATE THAT HIGHER ED
SHOULD HAVE BEEN INCLUDED IN
THIS BOND. AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS, THE BEMOANING THAT
FACT. IT'S UNFORTUNATE, BUT AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CRUZ
POINTS OUT, EVEN WITHOUT IT,
THIS MEASURE IS BOTH NECESSARY
AND HIGHLY LEVERAGED. SO THANK
YOU TO ALL WHO WORKED SO HARD TO
DRAFT, NEGOTIATE, AND FINALIZE
THIS MEASURE, INCLUDING ALL OF
THE DIVERSE STAKEHOLDERS WHOSE
INPUT INFORMED THAT WORK. AND IN
PARTICULAR, THANK YOU TO MR. IAN
JOHNSON OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF HIS VERY
HARD WORK, ESPECIALLY AND ON
THIS MEASURE. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NEWMAN. ALL DEBATE HAVING THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN, I ALL RODA-GIL ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLI NÓ
DODD I DORADO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE REDONDO I
JONES NO LAIRD I LIMÓN I MAGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN NIELLO I OKOBO I PODIUM I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO
NO SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB WIENER I
WILK I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO GILL GROVE
NGUYEN WAHAB I ON A VOTE OF 34
TO 3 ON THE URGENCY, 34 TO 3 ON
THE MEASURE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, MEASURES REPORTED
FROM POLICY COMMITTEES JULY 3RD
THROUGH THE 10TH, 2024 WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REREFERRED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WILL BE GIVEN
THEIR SECOND READING. AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED, PUBLISHED, AND
REREFERRED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE 29.10 B,
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON RULES. FILE
ITEM 192. ASSEMBLY BILL 3259. I
SEE MICROPHONES UP ON MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES WILL
BEGIN WITH SENATOR DODD AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER 207 AB
3285 FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU. THE DESK WILL NOTE
NEXT RECOGNIZED SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
REQUEST A UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN SB 1106, FILE ITEM 32 TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR FOR FURTHER
ACTION. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THAT
WILL BE THE ORDER OF THE DAY.
THANK YOU. AND AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR, I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST FOR ITEM 2068B 3261 BY
MR. MIKE FONG BE REMOVED FROM
CONSENT FILE AND MOVED TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THE DESK WILL
NOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR ROTH.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I WOULD REQUEST
THAT WE PULL FILE NUMBER A ONE
AS CR 80 OFF THE INACTIVE FILE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
THE DESK WILL NOTE. SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER 200 AB 2886 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE DESK WILL
NOTE SENATOR MENJIVAR. SHE'S NOT
PREPARED. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE PHÐ ITEM
195 AB 2003 43 FROM CONSENT, THE
DESK WILL NOTE HAVE ANOTHER ONE
OTHER REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
PLEASE REMOVE 837 AB 1147 ADDIS
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE AND PLACE
IT BACK ON FILE. THE DESK WILL
NOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
MENGIBAR. ANY FURTHER MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS OR NOTICES? MEMBERS
OKAY, WE ARE GOING TO MOVE NOW
TO AN ADJOURN IN MEMORY. I WANT
TO ASK THE MEMBERS TO BE AT
THEIR DESKS AND TO GIVE
ATTENTION TO SENATOR ASHBY FOR
AN ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY TO
UNFORTUNATELY, ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF ONE OF OUR SENATE FAMILY,
WHITNEY ELIZABETH HAMILTON
PASSED AWAY ON MAY 17TH AT JUST
36 YEARS OLD. WHITNEY IS THE
DAUGHTER OF TWO HONORED SENATE
STAFF RUSSELL GLADDEN, WHO
CURRENTLY WORKS IN SPECIAL
SERVICES, AND DENA LUCERO, WHO
WORKED IN SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
WHITNEY WAS A SACRAMENTO NATIVE
THROUGH AND THROUGH. BORN IN
SACRAMENTO IN 1987, SHE ATTENDED
BLESSED VIRGIN MARY CATHOLIC
SCHOOL, BECAME A VERY TALENTED
ATHLETE AT MIRA LOMA HIGH SCHOOL.
WHITNEY LATER ATTENDED FEDERICO
BEAUTY SCHOOL AND BECAME A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER. SHE LOVED TO
HELP HER CLIENTS FEEL AND LOOK
BEAUTIFUL. IN SEPTEMBER OF 2016,
WHITNEY MARRIED THE LOVE OF HER
LIFE, KATY HAMILTON IN MAUI.
THEY ENJOYED SPENDING TIME
TRAVELING, CAMPING, AND FISHING
WITH FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND
THEIR LITTLE DOGS. MARLEY COOPER
AND PHIL. WHITNEY WAS ADMIRED BY
ALL WHO KNEW HER. SHE WAS KNOWN
FOR HER KINDNESS, HER GENEROSITY,
HER OPTIMISM, PASSION, AND HER
EXCELLENT WORK AS AN ESTHETICIAN.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER WIFE,
KATY HAMILTON, HER PARENTS, DENA
AND RUSSELL, AND HER SISTER
JESSICA, SOME OF WHOM HAVE
JOINED US TODAY IN THE GALLERY.
IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
OFFER THE CONDOLENCES OF THE
STATE SENATE TO THE FRIENDS AND
FAMILY OF WHITNEY ELIZABETH
HAMILTON MEMBERS. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN ADJOURNING IN MEMORY OF
WHITNEY ELIZABETH HAMILTON.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ASHBY. THE
SENATE EXTENDS ITS DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS OF WHITNEY. ELIZABETH
HAMILTON. PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN OUR SENATE
JOURNAL, AND THAT WE MAY ADJOURN
IN HER BLESSED MEMORY.
MEMBERS. AS YOU KNOW, WE ARE, IN
SOME CASES, AWAITING ACTIONS
FROM THE ASSEMBLY. THIS
AFTERNOON. SO WE ARE MANAGING
OUR TIME TO. TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE WORK WE HAVE BEFORE US.
SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A SHORT
FIVE MINUTE RECESS. WE'D LIKE TO
ASK MEMBERS TO REMAIN HERE ON
THE FLOOR, WE'LL BE BACK IN JUST
A FEW MINUTES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE.
YOU KNOW THE INS AND OUTS OF THE
DAY. SENATORS ALL RIGHT. AS, AS
MEMBERS KNOW, THERE'S A LOT
GOING ON TONIGHT THAT WE HAVE TO
ORGANIZE. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE,
STARTS AND STOPS, AND THAT'S
WHERE WE ARE AT RIGHT NOW IN
FACT, WE ARE WAITING FOR SOME
ASSEMBLY ITEMS TO COME BACK TO
OUR HOUSE. THE ASSEMBLY IS
CURRENTLY TRYING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. DO YOU HAVE ANY ASSEMBLY
FRIENDS? PLEASE ENCOURAGE THEM
TO, TO GET THERE, UNTIL THEIR
UNTIL THEN, WE'RE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A RECESS. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A DINNER BREAK. NO, PEOPLE
ARE EXCITED ABOUT THAT, WITH
GREAT, GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
CATCH UP ON THINGS. SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A DINNER BREAK, A
RECESS UNTIL 6 P.M. MEMBERS. YOU
HEAR THAT? 6 P.M. WE'RE ASKING
ALL MEMBERS TO STAY HERE IN THE
CAPITOL, AS WE WAIT FOR THE
ASSEMBLY TO TAKE ACTION. AND
WE'LL BE BACK. WE'LL BE BACK
RIGHT AT IT, AT 6 P.M. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS.
THE TAXPAYER PROTECTION ACT
REMOVED FROM THE BALLOT. A MAJOR
LOSS FOR DEMOCRACY IN
CALIFORNIANS. UNNECESSARILY
FORCING POISON PILL AMENDMENTS
TO WHAT WERE A BIPARTISAN CRIME
BILLS. THANKFULLY, THOSE
AMENDMENTS WERE RIGHTFULLY
REMOVED. TRYING TO JAM A SOFT ON
CRIME MEASURE ONTO THE BALLOT TO
UNDERMINE THE ONE THAT'S ALREADY
QUALIFIED FOR THE BALLOT WITH
OVER 900,000 SIGNATURES.
THANKFULLY, THAT MEASURE WAS
RIGHTFULLY CANCELED LAST NIGHT
IN A MAJOR WIN FOR DEMOCRACY AND
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS, THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS KNOWN SINCE
DECEMBER OF 2022 THAT THE
DEADLINE TO PLACE ITEMS ON THE
BALLOT WAS JUNE 27TH, 2024. YET
THAT DEADLINE WAS IGNORED, WHICH
NECESSITATED NECESSITATED THIS
BILL. WITH THAT SAID, I WOULD
ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON AB 440.
THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SENATOR BLAKESBERG, YOU
MAY CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALL
VOTED YOU KNOW ARCHULETA? AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. NØ DODD. AYE. HUESO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. I. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO. OKOBO.
NO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO
SKINNER. I SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. ON A VOTE
OF 31 TO 8, THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO NEXT MOVE MEMBERS
TO ASSEMBLY MESSAGES. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. MR. PRESIDENT, I AM
DIRECTED TO INFORM YOUR
HONORABLE BODY THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDED. AND ON THIS DAY PASSED,
AS AMENDED, SB 867. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
HONORABLE BODY TO CONCUR IN SAID
AMENDMENTS. SUE PARKER, CHIEF
CLERK OF THE ASSEMBLY. ASSEMBLY
BILL ORDERED TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS,
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. THEN
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP SB 867 BY
SENATOR ALLEN. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 867 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ALLEN
OR SENATOR ALLEN. EXCUSE ME. AN
ACT RELATING TO SAFE DRINKING
WATER, WILDFIRE PREVENTION,
DROUGHT PREPAREDNESS, AND CLEAN
AIR BY PROVIDING THE FUNDS
NECESSARY THERE FOR THROUGH AN
ELECTION OF THE ISSUANCE AND
SELL BONDS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND FOR THE HANDLING
AND DISPOSITION OF THOSE FUNDS,
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY
THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR ALLEN, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MISTER PRESIDENT. I AM
PLEASED TO RISE TO PRESENT THE
SAFE DRINKING WATER, WILDFIRE
PROTECTION, WILDFIRE PREVENTION,
DROUGHT PREPAREDNESS, AND CLEAN
AIR BOND OF 2024, WHICH, IF
PASSED BY THE VOTERS, WOULD BE
THE MOST IMPORTANT INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC FINANCE FUNDING FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCY IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY. IN A YEAR WHERE
WE HAD TO CLAW BACK BILLIONS IN
CLIMATE FUNDING DUE TO BUDGET
CHALLENGES, THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO TACKLE SOME OF OUR STATE'S
MOST SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES,
BOTH NEXT YEAR AND FOR MANY,
MANY YEARS TO COME. THE BOND
WOULD PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE AND
MAJOR NEW CLIMATE INVESTMENTS
FOR EVERY REGION OF THE STATE,
INVESTING IN WATER SECURITY,
DROUGHT AND FLOOD MITIGATION,
WILDFIRE PREVENTION, PARKS AND
COASTAL RESILIENCE,
BIODIVERSITY, EXTREME HEAT,
CLEAN ENERGY AND SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE. IT'S CAREFULLY
CRAFTED, PRESERVING THE
LEGISLATURE'S AUTHORITY TO SHAPE
APPROPRIATIONS THROUGH THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS. IN LINE
WITH THE FUNDING POTS AND
GUIDANCE IN THE BILL, AND THIS
WILL PROVIDE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY. WE LEARN THAT AS WE
LEARN MORE IN THE COMING YEARS
ABOUT THE MARKET TRENDS AND THE
BOND MARKET AND INTEREST RATES
AND ALL THE REST, AND SO THAT WE
CAN REALLY MAKE CERTAIN THAT
DOLLARS ARE NOT LEFT ON THE
TABLE. THERE ARE LOTS OF THINGS
TO HIGHLIGHT IN THIS MEASURE.
IT'S A FIRST. IT'S GOT A FIRST
OF ITS KIND LANDMARK REQUIREMENT
THAT AT LEAST 40% OF THE BOND
FUNDS HAVE TO BE INVESTED IN
DISADVANTAGED, VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT SUFFER THE
MOST, THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES, MOST SERIOUS POLLUTION
IMPACTS AND CHRONIC
UNDERINVESTMENT. THIS
REQUIREMENT IS DIRECTLY MODELED
ON THE JUSTICE40 INITIATIVE
ADOPTED BY THE US GOVERNMENT. IT
ALSO INCLUDES ANOTHER FIRST $850
MILLION FOR CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENTS TO HELP MEET
CALIFORNIA'S ZERO CARBON ENERGY
TARGETS THROUGH PORT AND
OFFSHORE WIND INVESTMENTS,
INVESTING IN THOUSANDS OF
SKILLED, HIGH WAGE JOBS. THE
BIGGEST PORTION OF THE BOND OF
COURSE, IS IN WATER. CLEAN
DRINKING WATER FUNDS, WATER
RECYCLING AND GROUNDWATER
STORAGE. STORM WATER PROJECTS,
NEW WATER RESOURCES, ADDRESSING
FLOOD, FLOOD FUNDING, FUNDING TO
IMPROVE WATERSHED RESILIENCY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THERE'S
ALSO A VERY IMPORTANT WATER
SORRY FIRE RISK PORTION, $1.5
BILLION, VARIOUS POTS TO FUND
CRITICAL EFFORTS TO HARDEN
COMMUNITIES, MAKE THEM MORE FIRE
RESISTANT, FUEL REDUCTION
EFFORTS TARGETING EVERY AT RISK
AREA IN THE STATE. FUNDING TO
REDUCE FIRE RISKS ASSOCIATED
WITH TRANSMISSION LINES, WHICH
WE KNOW HAVE WREAKED HAVOC IN
MANY PARTS OF OUR STATE. THE
BILL ALSO SPENDS MORE THAN A
BILLION DOLLARS TO COMBAT SEA
LEVEL RISE AND IMPROVE COASTAL
RESILIENCY, ENSURING EQUITABLE
GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION. THERE'S
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS EXTREME
HEAT, FOCUSING ON OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES,
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES, URBAN FORESTS,
URBAN GREENING, AMONG OTHER
PROGRAMS. THERE'S ALSO OVER A
BILLION IN HISTORIC INVESTMENTS
TO PROTECT OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
AT RISK OF CLIMATE IMPACTS, TO
HELP US MEET OUR 30 BY 30 GOALS.
SMART CLIMATE, SMART AGRICULTURE
AND ALSO CLEAN ENERGY, AS WAS
MENTIONED, THIS IS ULTIMATELY
ABOUT CALIFORNIA TAKING ON THE
LEADERSHIP ROLE THAT WE HAVE
ALWAYS TAKEN ON TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE TODAY
WITH REGARDS TO CLIMATE CHANGE,
EXTREME HEAT, WILDFIRES THAT WE
ARE LIVING IN REAL TIME TODAY,
FLOODING AND COASTAL CLIFF
COLLAPSES. WE SAW LAST WINTER
THE BIODIVERSITY ESSENTIAL TO
OUR STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL
WELL-BEING, ALL OF WHICH ARE
DIRECT IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. IN THE END OF THE DAY,
IT'S ABOUT PUTTING FORTH
INVESTMENTS TODAY THAT WILL MAKE
LIFE BETTER FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. AND THAT ULTIMATELY
HAS BEEN THE GUIDING LIGHT THAT
HAS THAT HAS BEEN AT THE HEART
OF OUR NEGOTIATIONS. ARE THESE
GOOD INVESTMENTS FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS? ARE THESE THINGS
THAT WE CAN BE PROUD OF? THESE
THINGS THAT THAT THAT ARE OUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN WILL
BE HAPPY THAT WE SPENT MONEY ON
AND INVESTED IN IN THE END OF
THE DAY, WE KNOW THAT THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
ARE CONTINUING TO GROW. THERE'S
SOME EXTRAORDINARY ESTIMATES
THAT ARE COMING OUT. THE FOURTH
CLIMATE ASSESSMENT, THE IN THE
FOURTH CLIMATE ASSESSMENT, THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY STATES
THAT CALIFORNIA COULD FACE AN
ANNUAL COST OF OVER $100 BILLION
EVERY YEAR FROM CLIMATE CHANGE
BY 2050. IF NO ACTION IS TAKEN,
IT'S HARD TO WRAP YOUR HEAD
AROUND THAT NUMBER. IT
ULTIMATELY, IT'S ABOUT ENSURING
THAT WE'RE PUTTING IN THE
INVESTMENTS NOW THAT WILL REDUCE
THOSE COSTS IN THE FUTURE. THE
IMPORTANT ISSUE WAS RAISED
YESTERDAY AT THE AT THE SENATE
HEARING, THE OVERSIGHT HEARING,
HOW TO DOING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THAT OF COURSE, WAS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR FOCUS. WE REQUIRE
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY TO
PUBLISH A LIST OF PROJECTS ON A
PUBLIC WEBSITE, SO ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN SEE PRECISELY
WHERE THE MONEY IS SPENT. THE
LIST WILL DELINEATE NOT JUST HOW
BOND FUNDING IS USED, BUT ALSO
THE PROJECT'S ANTICIPATED
OUTCOMES. THE PUBLIC BENEFITS,
INCLUDING BENEFITS TO VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. IN FACT, IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED, I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CHECK OUT THE WEBSITE FOR PAST
BOND MEASURES WHERE YOU CAN SEE
EACH PROJECT, HOW IT IS FUNDED,
AND THERE REALLY ARE THOUSANDS.
SO MEMBERS. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS ENORMOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ALLEN.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I MUST RISE
IN IN OPPOSITION. AND I WANTED
TO SHARE WITH YOU WHY I'M IN
OPPOSITION. NOT THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF CHALLENGES OUT
THERE. OBVIOUSLY, ON A DAY WHERE
WE HAVE HEAT HOTTER THAN IT'S
NORMALLY BEEN. BUT I WAS HERE
UNDER PROP ONE WHERE WE
NEGOTIATED A DEAL THAT SAID WE
WERE ACTUALLY GOING TO DO
STORAGE, ABOVE GROUND STORAGE,
AND I VOTED FOR THE BOND MYSELF.
PROP 1 IN 2014. AND HERE WE ARE
IN 2024, AND WE'VE NOT PUT ONE
DROP OF WATER IN STORAGE. AND
THE PROJECTS WITH, WITH, BY THE,
BY THE WAY, RECORDS AMOUNT OF
MONEY IN OUR GENERAL FUND TO
HELP OUT COST MATCH. AND SO WHAT
ARE WE LAYING ON THE FUTURE OF
OUR GRANDCHILDREN AND OUR
CHILDREN? THE FACT THAT WE CAN'T
DELIVER A PROJECT IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN WE PUT BONDS UP. AND I'D
LIKE TO JUST I'M GOING TO MAKE
THIS VERY SIMPLE. WE'RE ALREADY
PAYING THIS IS A $10 BILLION
BOND FOR EVERY BILLION DOLLARS
THAT YOU BOND. IT'S $500 MILLION
IN DEBT SERVICE. OFF THE TOP OF
YOUR GENERAL ON TOP OF YOUR
BUDGET EVERY YEAR. SO
$10,000,010 BILLION. WHEN IT'S
FULLY BONDED OUT WILL BE A HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
THAT WE HAVE TO PAY BACK. IT'S
DOUBLE THE SIZE OF THE BOND. SO
IT WILL BE $20 BILLION. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED. AND THE
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
SIGNED INTO LAW AB 32 CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM. AND IT GENERATES
PAY ATTENTION. $5 BILLION A
YEAR. 2220, 24, 25 BUDGET FOR
CAP AND TRADE WAS $5.6 BILLION.
NOW, I WANT TO READ OFF WHERE
THOSE WHERE THE MONEY GOES TO
1.179 BILLION GOES TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL, 943 MILLION GOES TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS, TRANSIT AND INTERCITY
RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAMS, 471
MILLION LOW CARBON TRANSIT
OPERATION PROGRAMS 236 MILLION
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM 130 MILLION.
THERE'S STILL TWO AND A HALF,
ALMOST $3 BILLION LEFT OVER
EVERY YEAR. SO BETWEEN NOW AND
2050, WHICH THE AUTHOR STATED,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SPEND
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THIS FUND STAYING ON THE SAME
TRACK THAT IT IS, WILL GENERATE
$135 BILLION OFF THE BACKS OF
TAXPAYERS TODAY TO DO WHAT? TO
REDUCE CARBON AND HELP
CALIFORNIA LEAD THE WAY IN THE
NATION WHEN IT COMES TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. SO MEMBERS I WOULD LOVE
TO GET UP HERE AS A AS SOMEBODY
WHO SAID ON THE SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY BOARD FOR SEVEN
YEARS AND DID LOTS OF LAND
CONSERVATION DEALS AND DID A LOT
OF GOOD WORK, BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY, I JUST CAN'T SUPPORT A
BILL WHEN WE ALREADY HAVE $5
BILLION A YEAR GOING INTO CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM, WHICH IS A
TAX ON ENERGY, GASOLINE, ALL THE
THINGS THAT MAKE IT UNAFFORDABLE
TO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. AND NOW
ON TOP OF THAT, WE'RE GOING TO
ADD ANOTHER $10 BILLION ON TOP
OF THAT. SO I WILL BE VOTING NO
AGAINST SB 876 AND TRYING TO
SECURE A FUTURE FOR MY CHILDREN
TO BE ABLE TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DOLLY. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, I ALSO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND IS A
PROUD COAUTHOR OF SB 867, THE
SAFE DRINKING WATER WILDFIRE
PREVENTION, DROUGHT
PREPAREDNESS, AND CLEAN AIR BOND
ACT OF 2024. I'D LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA MONICA FOR BEING SO
DILIGENT ON THIS ISSUE AND
CONTINUE CONTINUE TO LEAD
CONSTANTLY, YEAR AFTER YEAR ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AND MAKING SURE
THAT, YOU KNOW, HE TAKES CARE OF
FUTURE GENERATIONS. GLAD TO ADD
MY VOICE TO THIS BOND, BUT I'M
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT SEVERAL
THINGS, AND I THINK THE
INVESTMENT THAT'S GOING TO BE
MADE AND ESPECIALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES, IS
SOMETHING THAT WE I THINK WE
WERE ALL PUSHING FOR
COLLECTIVELY. AND I THINK THAT'S
VERY MEANINGFUL BECAUSE THIS IS
NOT ABOUT JUST INVESTING WITHOUT
LOOKING AT THE BIGGER PICTURE,
YOU KNOW, THESE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES DESERVE TO HAVE
THOSE INVESTMENT PROJECTS IN
THEIR IN THEIR AREA, ESPECIALLY
AS WE KNOW IT WILL CREATE GOOD
PAYING JOBS OPPORTUNITY. THIS IS
NOT JUST FOR US, BUT
GENERATIONALLY. THIS IS GOING TO
YIELD YOU KNOW, AGAIN, WHAT WE
FIGHT FOR AND THAT IS, YOU KNOW,
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. I WAS VERY VOCAL
ABOUT MAKING SURE AS WELL THAT
WE INCLUDED FUNDING FOR REGIONAL
CONSERVANCIES, WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND I'M GLAD THAT
THIS IS A GREAT BALANCE. AND I
WANT TO THANK THOSE, NOT JUST
THE AUTHOR, BUT ALL THOSE THAT
SAID, YOU KNOW, IT WAS A LOT OF
HOURS OVER THE WEEKEND AT NIGHT,
AND I RECOGNIZE THE COMMITMENT
TO GETTING THIS TO THE FINISH
LINE. SO AGAIN, I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE THAT INVESTED THEIR
TIME. BUT CLEARLY 40% INVESTED
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IS
KEY FOR SOME OF US WHO HAVE
THESE, YOU KNOW, COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE REALLY, IN NEED OF
JOBS, IN NEED OF OPPORTUNITIES.
AND THANK YOU FOR THIS WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THOSE
DOLLARS TO OUR, OUR REGION. SO
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
AND, COLLEAGUES, I TOO WANT TO
THANK OUR FELLOW SENATOR ALLEN
FOR HIS HARD WORK ON THIS
INITIATIVE AND WORKING WITH THE
OTHER HOUSE ON THIS, SB SIX 867,
WHICH, IF CONFIRMED BY THE
VOTERS, WOULD PROVIDE 10 BILLION
OF DOLLARS IN CRUCIAL FUNDING
FOR CLIMATE RESILIENT
INFRASTRUCTURES. AND I WANT TO
SAY HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS FOR MY
DISTRICT, WHERE I HAVE THE
LARGEST URBAN OIL FIELD IN THE
COUNTRY, THE INGLEWOOD OIL
FIELD. THAT REGION ALONE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SURROUNDING
IT, STANDS TO GAIN UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENT, THIS IS A GROWING
CONSERVANCY OF URBAN COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE PARK POOR, THAT ARE
RESOURCE POOR. AND THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT THERE IS EQUITY IN
OUR NATURAL RESOURCES AND
CALIFORNIA, HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS INITIATIVE. THAT'S WHY I'M
EXCITED TO SEE THIS HISTORIC
INVESTMENT COME TO MY COMMUNITY.
AND I ENTHUSIASTICALLY,
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR MIN. SURE. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I JUST BRIEFLY
JUST WANT TO THANK THE PEOPLE
WHO WORKED ON THIS, INCLUDING
SENATOR ALLEN, SENATOR GONZALEZ,
AND OF COURSE, SENATOR LIMÓN,
WHO LED THIS EFFORT. I ALSO
WANTED TO THANK MY STAFF ON THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE FOR THE MANY, MANY
HOURS THEY SPENT ON THIS BILL.
THIS IS IMPORTANT. IT'S
ADDRESSING CRITICAL PRIORITIES.
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE
POINT HERE. THIS IS THE FISCALLY
PRUDENT THING TO DO. WE KNOW
THAT AN OUNCE OF PREVENTION IS
WORTH A POUND OF CURE, AND EVERY
DOLLAR SPENT ON PREVENTION SAVES
$6 IN THE LONG RUN. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR MIN.
SENATOR LIMÓN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. I RISE
AS A JOINT AUTHOR TO SB 867.
THIS IS THE SINGLE LARGEST
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC FUNDING FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCE IN THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA, AND THE
LARGEST INVESTMENT IN OUR
COUNTRY FROM ANY SINGLE
GOVERNMENT OUTSIDE OF THE
FEDERAL INFLATION REDUCTION ACT.
THIS FUNDING MAY NOT FIX ALL OF
OUR CLIMATE PROBLEMS, BUT THE
COST OF INACTION IS MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE TO OUR TAXPAYERS.
TODAY, WE HAVE EXTREME HEAT
WARNINGS ALL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WE HAVE THE THOMPSON FIRE
AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
EVACUATED, AND WE ARE LOOKING TO
PUT A BOND TO OUR VOTERS TO GIVE
THEM THE OPTION ON WHETHER OR
NOT THIS IS THE TYPE OF
INVESTMENT THAT WE WANT TO MAKE.
THE BOND WILL HELP WITH WILDFIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES. WATER
RESILIENCE, INVESTMENTS, ALL
NEEDED TO REDUCE SOME OF THE
IMPACTS THAT ARE BEING FELT
ACROSS OUR STATE. LAST WINTER,
WE SAW DEVASTATING FLOODING AND
COASTAL CLIFFS COLLAPSE IN OUR
STATE, NOT TO MENTION THE
CONSTANTLY DECLINING
BIODIVERSITY, ESSENTIAL TO OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL WELL-BEING. ALL
IMPACTS THAT WE SEE ON A REGULAR
BASIS IMPACTS THAT ARE FELT IN
58 COUNTIES AND OVER 480 CITIES
IN OUR STATE. THIS BILL PROVIDES
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTMENTS IN ALL
FOR ALL CORNERS OF OUR STATE.
FROM THE OREGON BORDER TO THE
MEXICO BORDER, FROM THE
COASTLINE TO THE SIERRA NEVADA'S.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS FEEL THE BENEFITS
OF MAKING THIS INVESTMENT. MANY
OF US IN THE ROOM AND IN THIS
LEGISLATURE HAVE LIVED THROUGH
THE IMPACTS OF WILDFIRE,
DROUGHTS, FLOOD AND EXTREME
HEAT. WE KNOW THEM. WE'VE
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES AND KNOW
WHAT THE IMPACTS ARE. THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND WILDFIRE
PREVENTION BOND IS A CHANCE TO
BUILD ON THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
BEEN DOING. IT TOOK A LOT TO GET
HERE, AND I WANT TO THANK THE
INCREDIBLE STAFF IN THE SENATE,
STAFF IN BOTH HOUSES, AND EVERY
MEMBER WHO WEIGHED IN TO PROVIDE
INPUT AND DIRECTION. THERE WAS A
WORKING GROUP. AND OF COURSE,
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA
LED THE WAY. AND ALL OF THAT IS
HOW WE GOT TO TODAY'S BOND. OUR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE THE CHANCE
TO MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS IN
CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND ALSO
MUST BE PROTECTED FROM THE
IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT AND HAVE
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO
COMBAT THESE CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS. THE BOND IS AN
INVESTMENT THAT WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS, NOT JUST TODAY,
BUT IN GENERATIONS TO COME. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LIMÓN. SEEING
NO MORE MICROPHONES UP, WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO SENATOR ALLEN TO
CLOSE. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR ALL YOUR
WONDERFUL COMMENTS. SPECIAL
THANKS TO THE INCREDIBLE STAFF.
AND, AND OUR AND OUR ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS AS WELL,
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE WORKING
GROUP AND THE EXCEPTIONAL CHAIR,
OUR EXCEPTIONAL WORKING GROUP
CHAIR, SENATOR LIMÓN, THANK YOU,
COLLEAGUES, FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
IN THIS VERY IMPORTANT ENDEAVOR.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO TO GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DAWLEY. NO. DODD. AYE. RAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
MINH. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
NO NILO. NO. JOBO AYE. PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORTANTINO. AYE WILK. IS THAT A.
THAT'S A VOTE OF 33 TO 6. WAIT
THIS THING IS NOT WORKING. 30.
THAT'S 33. SIX ON THE URGENCY.
33. SIX ON THE MEASURE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO DO JUST A COUPLE QUICK
THINGS HERE BEFORE WE CAN
FINISH. TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO GO
NEXT TO THE SECOND READING FILE.
SECOND READING FILE WILL BE
DEEMED READ. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WE
HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
THE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. IS
THERE ANY MEMBER WHO WOULD LIKE
TO REMOVE SOMETHING FROM THE
EITHER CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS.
ANYBODY WANT TO REMOVE ANYTHING.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO MICROPHONES
UP SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ALL
THE ITEMS ON BOTH CONSENT
CALENDARS. SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION 18. ASSEMBLY BILL
2283 2908 960. ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION 13. ASSEMBLY BILL
1996 2756 2663. SENATE BILL 1353
NINE 49 1024 1034, 1190 1385.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
192 190 (620) 220-7208. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 114.
SENATE RESOLUTION 68 7071.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDARS. ALAN,
I. ALVARADO I, ARCHULETA I ASHBY
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ.
DALLY I DODD. BARRASSO. TERRAZZO
I DODD I EGGMAN. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. I GROVE. I OR DODD. Ó
I. JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MEN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NILO I OKOBO I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CORTEZ I EGGMAN
I. IT'S A VOTE OF 39 TO 0 ON
FILE ITEM 20820 39 ZERO ON THE
REMAINDER OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO LIFT THE CALLS. JUST
HOLD ON A MINUTE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM 39. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALLS AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD I
MENGIBAR I IT'S A VOTE OF 40 TO
0. SR 99 IS ADOPTED. THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
SENATE. SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU. HEY,
THERE WE GO. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WITH. WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE. IF
IT'S ALL RIGHT WITH THE
PRESIDING OFFICER, I'M GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER TO BE ABLE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS AND THEN, PLEASE, THROUGH
THE PRESIDING OFFICER. ALL
RIGHT. THE ACTING GOVERNOR
DEFERS TO THE MINORITY LEADER,
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU, MR. PRO
TEM. I JUST WANTED TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSE BRIEFLY AND SAY THANK
YOU, EVERYBODY FOR THIS
INCREDIBLE WEEK. WHAT STARTED
OFF, CRAZY IS ENDING CRAZY. BUT
WORKING TOGETHER, I THINK WE
HAVE SHOWN THAT CALIFORNIANS, WE
CAN ALL ADVOCATE FOR THE ISSUES
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO US, EVEN
THOUGH SOMETIMES WE DISAGREE,
BUT STILL HONOR EACH OTHER'S
PROFESSIONALISM AND CHERISH EACH
OTHER'S FRIENDSHIP. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU AND WISH EVERYBODY
A GREAT, FANTASTIC, HAPPY
INDEPENDENCE DAY. LET'S HAVE A
GREAT SUMMER RECESS AND COME
BACK IN AUGUST READY TO GET BACK
TO WORK. THANK YOU, SENATOR
JONES. SENATOR MCGUIRE, ACTING
GOVERNOR MCGUIRE. THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND I WILL BE
BRIEF AND SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
TREMENDOUS WORK OVER THESE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS. AS WE CLOSED IN
ON THIS JULY 3RD DEADLINE. AND I
GOT TO SAY TOGETHER, WE HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED A HELL OF A LOT
BEFORE I GET INTO MY BRIEF
REMARKS, I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU. THE GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN
DIEGO, FOR HER AMAZING WORK
HONORING OUR BIRTHDAY TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR
BLAKESBERG. AND AS A SENATE, WE
WORKED TOGETHER. WE WORKED
TOGETHER FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'VE ADVANCED
IMPACTFUL POLICIES. WE'VE
ADVANCED IMPACTFUL POLICIES TO
THE ASSEMBLY, A COUPLE HUNDRED
BILLS THAT YOU'VE ALL CHAMPIONED
THAT WILL POSITIVELY CHANGE
EVERY COMMUNITY IN EVERY CORNER
OF THIS STATE. WE PASSED AN ON
TIME, BALANCED BUDGET THAT
PROTECTED OUR PROGRESS, KEPT OUR
RAINY DAY FUND HEALTHY, AND
LIFTED UP MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED BIPARTISAN BILLS THAT
BROUGHT NEEDED REFORM TO PARGA,
WHICH WILL BENEFIT SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WILL CONTINUE TO
PROTECT WORK AND FAMILIES IN
THIS STATE. WE'VE CREATED AN
INSURANCE WORKING GROUP LED BY
THE SENATOR FROM BALDWIN PARK
AND THE SENATOR FROM LONG BEACH
THAT WILL HELP STABILIZE OUR
INSURANCE RESIDENTIAL MARKET AND
MORE TO COME THIS AUGUST, WE
PROMISE. AND THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF SO MANY ON THIS
FLOOR, WE PASSED TWO BONDS, TWO
BONDS THAT WILL BENEFIT
GENERATIONS OF CALIFORNIANS. AND
WE NEED TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
LEADERS WHO BROUGHT THEM FORWARD.
AND I'M GOING TO END IT RIGHT
HERE. LET'S BE CANDID. THE LAST
FEW WEEKS, THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS
EASY. AND WE ALWAYS SAID THERE
ARE 1000 DAYS IN JUNE AND THAT
1000 DAYS IN JUNE GAVE WAY TO
THE 4TH OF JULY FESTIVITIES,
WITH AN AIRING OF GRIEVANCES.
BUT, COLLEAGUES, WE'RE GOING TO
FINISH STRONG AND WE'RE GOING TO
FINISH WHAT WE STARTED AND I
WANT TO BE SPECIFIC ABOUT THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING FORWARD OUR
RETAIL THEFT, SAFER CALIFORNIA
BILLS IN AUGUST, GET THEM PASSED
AND KEEP CALIFORNIANS SAFE. THE
SENATE, THE SENATE HAS THE BEST
STAFF TEAM IN THE NATION, AND WE
NEED TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR AMAZING SENATE
STAFF TEAM. THE INDIVIDUAL
OFFICE TEAMS, THE SECRETARY'S
OFFICE, THE SERGEANTS OFFICE,
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL AND
THE DESK STAFF LED BY THE ONE,
THE ONLY. I WANT TO HEAR YOU
LOUD AND PROUD, EVERYBODY. LET'S
GIVE IT UP FOR BERNIE MCNULTY.
WE LOVE BERNIE. AND WITH THAT,
COLLEAGUES, WE WISH YOU A VERY
HAPPY 4TH OF JULY. STAY SAFE.
STAY COOL, STAY VIGILANT. OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS AUGUST
FIFTH, 2024 AT 2 P.M. HAPPY
FOURTH. MR. THANK YOU, SENATOR
MCGUIRE. THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED. WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY, AUGUST 5TH AT 2 P.M.